- On pourrait croire que
c'est une expérience
comme bien d'autres à Singapour,
s culinaire.
Mais la viande
qu'on apprête en cuisine a été
fabriquée en laboratoire.
déguster cette première
mondiale, un ancien
chef triplement étoilé.
MÉNARD, Fondateur, Société
Conseil culinaire BRUNO MÉNARD
- Il est certain que c'est
le déguste, c'est de la viande.
a texture, on a du goût.
Ça a du goût de volaille.
- Le produit a été conçur
de cellules-souches de pouletpr.
La viande est cultivée dans
un bioréacteur de 1200 lit tard,
quelques kilogrammes sont prêts.
Selon l'approbation
gouvernementale,ite et en format
de croquettes seulement.
let est servi uniquement
à Singapour depuis déjà un an,
le fruit de quatre ans de
pour l'entreprise californienne,
qui l'a élaboré.
Une soixantaine d'entreprises
les travaillent
sur de tels projets de viande
synthétique. Elles disent
mondiale qui devrait augmenter
de 70 % d'ici 2050.50.50.50.50.
La viande cultivée en
laboratoire permettrait
écologique du secteur de près
de 80 %, selon ctimés.
(en anglais)
système alimentaire", croit-il.
"Il faut revoir notresystème al.
La viande cultivée
en laboratoire soulève
Certaines entreprises utilisent
rmones de croissance,
par exemple. D'autres, comme
Eat Just, utilisent du sérum
culture, ce qui est jugé cruel.
D'un ue médical,
ce spécialiste rappelle
qu'il faudrait plutôt
Dr MARTIN JUNEAU, dir.
prévenitut cardiitut cardiitut L
- C'est qu'on serait mieux
d'avoir une augmentation p
riche en végétaux, en protéine
végétale, que de se lancer dans
la viande cultivpour la santé.
- Pour le moment, la production
de ces croquettes de poulet
e minime et les coûts
exorbitants. Mais le produit
pourrait éventuellement
la viande d'élevage. Le chef
Bruno éjà hâte.ement
une évolution 2, 3, 4 surle pro.
qu'on va pouvoir contrôler
les textures et ça deviendt.
- Après Singapour,
ar et les États-Unis,
l'entreprise Eat Just espère
obtenir bientôt le feu vert
ble inévitable que
la viande cultiv